Ah
Oh my god, my hands are there! Hi! Can you hear me good? I feel like the audio might be a little bad.
I don't want it to be cutting me out at all.
Hello, hello, hello! You sound great. Am I getting cut off? Should I make it even louder?
Testing, testing, testing, testing, testing, testing.
I know I'm not muted this time.
Okay.
I can't find the scuff. I know!
Last hand cam stream, it was so scuffed. The ASMR was so bad. I'm so sorry.
I figured out how to fix my camera so now you can actually see in good quality.
Also, my tracking isn't going to be as good because it was harder to set up.
It's not as simple as it looks. Okay, there's a lot of wires around me.
And there's a lot of technology around me, okay?
So sorry if the tracking isn't as good.
Hello, welcome. What happened to your pink setup? What do you mean by pink?
Oh, you mean like my mousepad? I'm on the floor today.
This is the two that I got. They're pop and cook and so basically they're just candy.
They're just candy. They're just candy and they look like food.
So this one's like the American one and then this one's like the Japanese one.
It's just the Japanese one.
So we're going to make, I don't know if we'll make both of these, but we're going to make at least one of them.
But yeah, we're on the floor. Floor gang. Floor wire at random? No.
The whole thing's going to come tumbling down.
Yeah, floor shim. I'm on a blanket today. Should I move my, I know you can see like my iPhone over there.
Sorry, sorry if it's annoying.
Which one do you want to, oh wait, first before we do anything.
The long awaited introduction. I have to introduce you to my rats now, don't I?
Right? Yep. It's time for you to meet the family.
We're getting really serious now. Oh no.
Is my camera getting fucked up? What are those? What are those?
Do you see that?
Bro, I thought there was going to be no scuff. This is a new camera. What the hell?
You do see that? Radiation?
Cough.
Hmm.
Dammit.
Sigh.
Okay, I'm going to switch cameras to my, um, to my phone. I'm going to use my phone as a camera.
Okay?
So I'll be right back.
I'll be right back. I'm going to try using my phone. I'm so pissed this is a new camera. What the fuck?
Okay.
Let me try something.
are you gay? oh my god! why are you acting so gay?
i'm sorry immy but i think the glitch wasn't the camera this and screen was glitching too
huh sorry oh my god it played on my freaking speakers i'm sorry let me change that too
it wasn't the camera
huh
this and screen was glitching too what isn't my whole isn't my whole bs
it was only glitching in the one spot bro you guys are confusing me
hey okay i used a different here's my vtube studio okay i used a different um
i use i have to change my blanket because i fucking got water all over it um
um
you can't donate you should be able to
yeah i had to change my blanket because i got water all over it um
i don't want you to see my feet though oh my god
okay well here's our new setup if you see my feet tell me so i can move move them away
okay are we safe are we safe can you see good is it glitching
this is a different camera i know my i know my tracking is bad but other than that
okay nails thank you thank you thank you no glitch no free feet looks good looks good looks good
okay okay tracking is fine it keeps uh breaking because i'm looking away from
i'm looking away from the um
from the fucking i can't i can't i can't think from the iphone looks good your
blankets don't thank you you sound like lividy i wonder why
okay okay fucking hell i'm so sorry for all this stuff let me situate i need to use
i need to use the boxes to like situate okay oh wow we have a lot more space now here okay
i'm gonna go get let me i'm gonna go get more water because i spilled all of it on my blanket
and then i'm going to show you my fucking rats and then we're gonna start cooking okay okay
lividy who's that sounds new i don't know who that is i've never heard of her
um all right i'll be right back i gotta get more water
don't
oh my god hello oh okay okay we're ready it's your birthday today cake and ice cream
is on the way what what do you mean it's my birthday are you ready to read the to meet
the rats are you ready to meet the rats yes okay okay okay let me show you the
first one well whoever I can get in my freaking hands first okay okay our first
contender is Luna all right no pixie sorry oh she's so scared this is pixie
there you go oh she's really scared oh she's scared of the light I think it's
okay pookie oh she's she's she wants underneath my legs I'm trying to like
get my my knees in shot so she'll come out come oh you can't see her she's scared
should I just turn off my model cuz it's so laggy come on there you go there you
go come on out okay I'm gonna turn off my model completely it's like really laggy
cool let's get the next one out
okay this one this one is Luna oh she's not as scared and then let me see if I
can get I can honestly say that I never expected to like your streams as much as
I do you are honestly the best and I hope to be able to enjoy your streams for years to
come hey this one's in her pod that one's Esteban okay I think the last one already
left the cage so she'll be walking around um how many rats you have I have four stop
don't look at my feet stop stop stop don't look at them okay now we can actually start
on the cooking cooking in the nook and which one do you want to do first I'll let you choose
do you want to do the the American one do you want to do McDonald's or do you want to
do um what is this what would this be called like should I do a poll wait I can't do a
poll can I how do I make a poll is there a mod here that can make a poll for me can a
mod please please make a poll for which one you can do like the colors um green or blue
this one's green and this one's blue mod check any mods in chat hello am I alone in here damn
we can't you can't make polls oh I'm the only one that can make a poll shit all right well I
want to choose this one because I want to if the mods can't do it I'll just choose let me wipe off
all the freaking lube from my camera make sure it's nice and clear there's chat yep okay great
hmm I'll move that further away we're doing work here first what's that what I didn't use it for
anything I don't know what you're talking about what I'll fucking eat scissors right right let me
go get scissors and then I have a fun update to give you guys I have a really fun update to give
you let me move my freaking phone too
okay brave to leave food and rat distance they will they will be they will be going for it trust
me they'll be going for it okay let me cut it open so my update where are rats they're walking
around I can't just force them to cook with me they're walking around let them walk around
they're not actually sitting on my head and cooking with me why are you acting so gay finally
caught an amibe zoo stream she spent three hours trying to make food from a box and then
accidentally showed her feet live on stream great to tuber she is shut up shut up I didn't spend
three hours but thank you for the tip geez it was more like it I actually spent like I actually
spent like an entire hour setting up the hand cam only for it to not work and then I have to go
back to my old shitty webcam that I used before well anyways here's your update so did I choose
the American one oh I did I forgot him I think it looks okay that's good that's good as long as you
like it oh my god I'm sorry I'm coughing so much it's not really helping that I am streaming
and talking loudly maybe I should talk quieter we can do like a little key ASMR I'm not okay I'm
sick as the buns looking at me right here's my story yesterday it's not really story it's just
something I want to tell you yesterday I was posted a picture on Twitter dot com of two are you gay
well why are you acting so gay can't always catch streams live but I'm happy to watch when I can
and sometimes even see toes keep up the great work sis thank you thank you for the tip
it's okay you don't have to watch them live you don't have to be here I have I'm really
thankful that you are here in the first place though so yesterday I posted a picture on Twitter of
some toys wink wink and I tried them out yesterday you heard me you heard me try it yesterday the
one I use well my hands are shaking the one I used for the audio that I posted yesterday was the
pink one and I'm sorry to disappoint you for actually both toys I'm sorry to disappoint you
pink one I couldn't figure out how to get it to work well because like from the shape of it it's
supposed to like how am I supposed to describe this on YouTube so from this okay from the shape of
it looks like it's supposed to like like like like it's like this shaped right so it looks like
it's supposed to go like that right like inside but like it was just kind of like like I couldn't
get it deep enough so it was kind of just like hanging out like like this instead of going like
I need to rip this off to really give you a good visualization here alright
alright so imagine this box is me right this is this is this is me and that's my underside so the
toy is like this shaped right so I thought it would go in like that but I couldn't get it in to go
like that it was kind of just hanging out like this it wasn't even like it's supposed to be like it
was frustrating it still felt good but it was frustrating that's all I have to say any um any
advice is appreciated please are the rats albino um Luna has red eyes but I don't think she's
considered albino we getting more feet did I show you more feet by accident oh shit I'm really
late on chat can we do this with shadow puppets what do you mean shadow puppets
no it wasn't double it wasn't a double toy was it wait was it did I use it wrong
please don't tell me I use the toy wrong that would suck I don't think so oh yeah right the
wand so the black one was a wand I think I just received a faulty product because even though
I charged it it still doesn't turn on good I'm such a fucking failure I charged it a lot and it
still doesn't turn on I don't know what to do like I've I even looked at the instructions
which I never do me instructions I mean okay I'll be looking at the instructions for this
but I usually never look at the instructions so I think I just received a faulty product I know
it's so disappointing does it require it does require an app and I did get the app and I did
use the app and the app is really fun hey the app is so fun but um it wouldn't it just wouldn't
turn on and it wouldn't connect so yeah that's a shame thank you for the burp readings
maybe if you give us a demonstration we can help you figure it out I'm not giving you a
demonstration wow dirty minded I think this is supposed to be a cutting board for me to use so
I'm gonna cut it out should I use this like I feel like I need a flatter surface for this
hello Esteban do you want to say hi come say hi to the viewers come here come on
I'm say hi oh she's too shy okay fine
no stop looking stop looking oh there she is also I saw some comments cuz I be looking at you
guys I know I'm every single one of you doesn't matter where you're from I'd be looking at what
you're saying and I saw some comments saying oh what she Esteban do you want me to cut you
because you're playing a really dangerous game right now um I saw some comments saying what she
she farted in her microphone that's gross I'm not watching streams anymore I don't want to play
with you anymore good leave I don't want you in my stream anyways if you can't appreciate my
forts I don't want you you're here for the girlfriend experience you think girls don't
fart get out of here you think girls don't poop you're in for a real surprise you're in
for a really Esteban look how cute she is I love her I love her so much I'm surprised Esteban is
the most explorative yeah girls poop and girls fart and you gotta kind of just learn to deal with
it and if you want to be my boyfriend you got to learn all about my pooping and farting she's
on my shoulder right now unfortunately I will not be able to show you that oh you want to hear her
sniff the camera I mean not the camera sniff the microphone
that's right if it's in me I'm down for anything that's right that's what I want to hear
isn't Esteban a male name dude it's a rat it's a fucking rat what do you even mean a male name
it's a rat do you think she knows she's a girl do you think she hears me call her name do you
think she hears me say the word Esteban and she thinks oh fuck that bitch she called me she named
me after a man no it's just a rat who cares I don't care she's not gonna get bullied by the other rats
who is gonna bully her the babies because they're the only ones with female names
rats are very smart they're not they're not that smart they're not that smart
she's not sensitive oh my god no absolutely not the sensitive ones are the babies
Esteban is one of the least sensitive ones and I think you're I think you might need me another one
Dennis is very shy that's why I didn't pick her up and show her to you but she's near me right now
fish who you call an Esteban I am Princess Buttercup no her name is not Princess Buttercup
her name is Esteban deal with it how'd you get your rats um
oh my god
it all started when I wanted a hamster and I looked up on google hamster videos
or not on google but on youtube hamster videos and um
well I was looking at videos of hamsters I learned that hamsters don't really care about their owners
that much are these instructions
I will keep this for instructions okay
so I learned that hamsters don't really care about their owners that much
and in my head I was like if I'm gonna get a pet and if it's gonna look this cute it's gotta care
about me I'm sorry it's gotta care about me because if I'm gonna care about some cute little
creature I wanted to care about me in return you know I was a little lonely yeah I was a little
lonely and I needed a pet to love me back I wanted a pet that loved me so yeah
so um I think I don't know how I just found out that some people kept rats as pets too
when I was um when I was looking like
you know looking through pet videos of small animals I debated on getting mice
maybe but then I found out that mice also don't really are you stealing your shit
I found out that mice also don't really like you back either so finally I landed on rats
hamsters die in some weird ways
oh my god
they don't it's not that they die in weird ways they're just really neglected animals
it's kind of depressing how neglected poor hamsters are
are they gay why are you acting so gay
thank you unlucky genius for the three dollars why do you keep why do you guys keep giving
three dollars and 33 cents I keep seeing 333 is there a reason can you like not are you
guys like in on it somehow you didn't see my shadow well yeah angel numbers oh it's one of the
default options oh okay I was just wondering why that specific number I was like why is everyone
giving three dollars and 33 cents thank you though thank you I appreciate you
all right um
anyways so
fuck me oh my god I'm losing my voice holy shit hello hello wait
hello okay I should probably talk quieter sorry it's gonna be an asmr stream it's an asmr stream
now so um anyways um
um
as the one just fucking turned over my cup of water okay so um I landed on rats and I was like
okay let me get a rat
wait I can't speak Japanese I don't know which one to use
shit wait
do I use the yellow one but these are fries oh yeah these are fries okay
um what was I talking about right I landed on rats
and at first I was like okay let me go to the pet store and buy a rat
well buy two rats because they need to be in pairs um but then I saw the prices at the pet store
and I was like holy shit yeah no it's like $20 per rat are you shitting me
am I willing to spend like thousands of dollars in vet in vet um fees of course of course of course
am I willing to spend $20 on a rat no I'm not spending $20 on a rat so I went on Kijiji
which is the Canadian version of um Craigslist um and I just happened to um
what are you making I'm making candy I happened to be really lucky and I found
um some random teenager that was giving away her two rats
how much do I put is there a line
just pick one up from the subway no how much do I put
oh I use this to measure okay are you gay why are you acting so gay
a couple of years ago I threatened my family with the purchase of five guinea pigs if we
didn't finally get a dog after years of breaking promises long story story we got a dog
how is getting a guinea pig a threat that's not a threat what do you mean
threat oh you know what I can do what do you mean threaten my family thank you for the
$420 though I think it was $420
that's not a threat I want guinea pigs guinea pigs was one of my options if I wasn't gonna
get rats I was gonna get guinea pigs let me use this straw one
right fuck oh fuck it won't come out god damn it okay
oh this is a bad idea should I just dip maybe I'll just dip
but five of them five guinea pigs sounds fine are you kidding me I love five guinea pigs I already
have four rats so yeah I found a random teenager um who was giving away their rats on could Gigi
and that started my journey of rats and ever since then I've gotten more an estaban and
deniser from a rat rescue they're not they're not from kijiji yeah and pixie and luna are
from kijiji though I'm actually allergic to guinea pigs oh no that's a sad that's a sad sad depressing
life yes they do need rat friends rats do get lonely is denison menace absolutely why did why do
you think I called her den is yeah I tried to do that but um this straw is like stuck in there
it has like um a stopper so I can't take it out yeah
no it's not a stanley cup it's just a random cup
the upkeep for five is never ending they also fight constantly wait guinea pigs fight oh
fuck I'm not even paying attention to what I'm doing here I don't I don't think this is enough water
this is nowhere near enough water damn it what if I just
or I guess I can do it
I thought guinea pigs liked each other that's why you get multiple because they want to be together
stop making imie excuse her canadianness what do you mean
so get the rats and pairs if you get them okay perfect for needing them catch on in deku
and then that way you can make them kiss and roleplay as kachan and dick
that would be so funny
it's already gonna be botched what why this it's not botched I still feel like it's not enough
um I still feel like it's not enough though and not enough water
kachan you have some cheese on your lips is that lips kachan you have some cheese on your lips
leave me alone deku kachan let me lick it off of you
it's gonna become too liquidy shut up shut up nerd I can do what I want
okay now what do I do does it put in the oven
oh I was supposed to microwave it
is that a microwave oh you can't see is that a microwave that looks like a microwave
oh I'm supposed to microwave this shit multiple times oh you bitch
microwave
this one doesn't have a microwave
man man
okay I'm gonna go microwave it I really don't want to I don't want to leave the bedroom I don't
want to leave you alone don't go sniffing in my underwear okay you stay right here while I'm gone
I don't want you snooping around my bedroom okay okay how long do I microwave it for
I can't read Japanese what does it say
uh
I'm trying to read it um
you guys know no promises about tree fitty one hour okay you're not helping
I'm gonna assume it's 40 to 30 seconds I'm guessing that's what that means you
can't even see that probably um but yeah I'm gonna assume it's 40 to 30 seconds
so I'm gonna put it for 40 seconds because I have a small microwave you stay right here okay
don't do anything sus I'll know if you do okay okay
so
guys she stole one of my ingredients are you shitting me right now
oh my god what do I do what do I do okay let me turn off my camera so I can chase her
okay well I'm an idiot she stole the empty package so it's okay
she just stole the empty package I should have put it in here all right I thought
she stole one of the ingredients that I would need but she didn't she got me yep
she got me false alarm first false alarm so I brought cheese for the rats and
also for me cuz I'm I like cheese
oh my god don't eat that here have some cheese take it take the cheese there you
go good girl here you can have some cheese Venice
okay she left me I missed you I missed you too I'm gonna be eating Havarti
cheese cuz it's my favorite type of cheese there she is hello this is Dennis
you can't really see her she's very shy and she also likes to bite there you go
right right back to cooking I'm so I'm so not not organized here I'm so sorry we
gotta get ourselves organized okay there now I'm organized okay wait where's my
cup of water oh there okay so this is how it turned out um it smells like it
smells like cake kind of like a cookie and I guess I'm supposed to cut it now
into the shapes I guess this is my knife it's not working it's really hard
should I just snap it what do I do does it actually look good by the way I'm not
gonna be eating these afterwards so I don't care if my my rats put their face
in it I'm not gonna be eating them I can't cut it okay okay well she's still she's
still half of my fries um okay there we go I can break it I'm just gonna break
them do you want the other give it back give it back give it back give it back please
please I need fries for my burger I need fries for my big triple I need fries for
my big triple burger combo leave me alone go wait um oh maybe maybe I shouldn't
maybe I shouldn't have put it in for 40 seconds that's our fries I'm sorry they're
not good I tried my hardest I'm so sorry oh well I'm gonna put the fries somewhere
where they can't get it okay here you guys can have cheese don't don't steal my
fries but you can have cheese you too Dennis here okay she's running away from
me yeah they're just boiled potatoes they're just boiled potatoes
yeah I like boiled potatoes too don't eat my potatoes take the cheese
sorry let me finish my cheese here don't take my potatoes don't take my
potatoes don't take my potatoes take the cheese take the cheese take the cheese take
the cheese okay okay where do I put this where they can't get it I'm gonna put
in one of the bags actually do I have a bag to put this in but I was not very
prepared for this dream as you can tell where do I put where should I put where
should I put my fries um I'm Marcy's here hi Marcy um okay I'm gonna be right
back I'm gonna go get like a like a Tupperware cuz I'm gonna need to I mean
I'm gonna need a place to put all the finished food and I don't want them to
be stealing it it's my fries I've been giving you guys cheese okay I'll be
right back oh you you hate me she hates being pet
don't steal my don't steal my knife don't steal my knife give me my knife
Jesus Christ okay don't steal it go away I need my cooking utensils go away
go away okay I'll be right back
okay I'm gonna be storing all food inside of this Tupperware where no rats
can steal it from me okay good good job good job good job Amy you're so smart I
know I know I am thank you Amy okay I lost chat
is she be here too no she be not here is she good girl I know thank you okay
what's the next step the next step is to make the burger patty okay so here's the
patty
she be being a lamb oh is she be playing cult of the lamb see the way to
get her to go away from you is to try to pet her cuz she hates getting pet I
love this rat I love her too she's very explorative and also keeps trying to
steal everything don't steal that don't steal it don't steal my shit you can
smell but you can't steal there you go that's right you can smell it but you
can't steal it all right okay that's enough that's enough go away go away go
away come on go away okay maybe I should put her back in the cage she's the
only one that's really causing me issues
all right put the patty is this the right thing oh shit these are the
burger buns wait no these are the patties no these are the patties what all
the patties supposed to go in here she's trying to steal my cheese package
oops the patty is supposed to go in here isn't it okay um how am I gonna put the
patty in there get your freaking nose out of my candy get your nose out of my
candy go away she's like snorting it please please five seconds apiece thank
you okay I'm gonna I'm gonna cut it cuz I put it it's this was supposed to go in
here yeah so I'm gonna cut it and and flip it over okay come on I gotta cut it
away from her she stole it okay well I guess we're not having cola she's
messing with it now okay I'm hoping that's gonna distract her so I can
actually cook I need a cook
oh my god I'm gonna cry this is the scuffiest dream ever my burger
come away you're making it work
what do I do what do I do I'm gonna cry I can't make a burger without the
patty it's not salvageable no it's not what do I do I just got a pile of crack
cocaine on my blanket let us wrap go vegan okay how do I clean this um okay
I'm just gonna go get some napkins this wasn't supposed to be so difficult if
the pun wasn't being a little shit you hear that don't steal the box she's just
licking it off we're making crack now so let's just snort it off of the blanket
you know put in a line just for you there you go there sniff it up go on
sniff it up we're truly cooking here this has devolved into into real cooking
okay I'm gonna go get some napkins I have no way of I don't I don't really want to pull out the
vacuum because I feel like that's gonna be really annoying so I'm gonna go get
napkins and see if I can try to pick up all this dust
crack pile get out of the crack pile okay I want to see if I can try wedding this
napkin a little bit and seeing if it'll like pump up wow I shouldn't have wet it
should I have what am I doing wrong here bro my beautiful blanket my beautiful
beautiful blanket oh fuck it smells delicious though I don't want a vacuum
it's too much work right now I'm trying to wait I'm trying to I'm trying to cook
right now okay so I've decided to bring a cutting board
okay there we go and now you have somewhere to focus on the on the carpet here because
it's a very busy we got a very busy stream going on here don't leave okay
I see chessboard more like my chessboard it's really dirty I don't like I'm not don't worry
about it don't even look at it don't even look at it right um so we're gonna I'm gonna try making
a patty anyways um we're gonna try making a patty with the very little amount of she's
trying to lick it from the side with the very little amount of patty um patty powder we have
left okay I love your nails thank you thank you sir I haven't been able to read chat much
just because my fucking rats they stole my knife didn't they they stole my knife didn't
they it's not here all right I'm trying to get stop it stop it I've had it up to here with you
okay that probably is more than enough water this is gonna be the patty I think it should be
enough it smells really good oh fuck it smells so good it kind of looks like cacao
oh did I I think I spilled more um okay come on um maybe it's not enough for a patty
do you think it's enough should I try to microwave this like literal shit pile should I try to
microwave this little literal shit pile I have in front of me here what do I do with this should
I eat it I'm not gonna eat it I don't want to see any comments being like ill Amy did Amy ate
blank Amy ate a thing that her rat sniffed shut up me and my rats are one okay um I'm gonna try to
microwave this little piece of shit here I don't know if it'll end up good but I'll try okay um let me
should should I try to shape it into a patty shape first in there shape into a patty this is um
we're on a budget okay this is a budget burger we don't really have a lot of money for meat meat is
really expensive nowadays so you know it's gonna be really thin I'm sorry all right I'm gonna go
microwave this I'm gonna microwave it for like how does it say oh I have to make everything I have
to make the buns to first oh okay all right let's make the buns where do I put the buns oh the
buns go in the same thing okay okay that's because you shop at Loblaw's stores hmm where do you shop
doesn't Loblaw's like literally own everything oh fuck it smells really good
we'd still eat it oh really you would really eat my cooking after my rats sniffed on it and
licked it I don't shop I steal like a rat yes you would eat my cooking oh thank you thank you
I'm happy you would do that we must show you how much we love you you're too nice maybe I'll give
you a little toe slip just for that okay there you go there's a little reward for being so nice
um right so she stole my little container for water so um how much to okay well I need I okay I'll
just eyeball it we love Amy toes yes you're welcome you're very welcome the grippers were out for
point two seconds okay um that's one I feel like I'm using a syringe right now I'm back in
lab class using a syringe training chat with toes now I was I didn't think of it as a strategy I
was truly just rewarding you for good behavior that's all it's not I'm not training you
I missed it can you do it again nope nope nope only once you just get is it supposed to look like
this this looks kind of gross you can only get it once okay no don't look at her standing try to
get it out your nails hurt be careful when causing me trouble all stream did you know
she was one of my freaking wet best-behaved rats before this did you know that because it
doesn't you can't really tell about it anymore can you you act like you you act like I never
feed you that's how you're acting right now maybe she is acting up for the camera I can
hear the other ones chewing on the cup that she stole from me too I feel like I need to add more
water this is not working out you're so fat what happened to you why'd you gain so much weight
yeah she wants to be a streamer get out of my get out of my bogear
why is that dog so small I don't know I think she kind of just came like that she was just born
like that what's archetype architect posting what does that mean I keep seeing people say
architect architect architect this architect that what's architect mean what does that mean what
is an architect can someone tell me like is it just is it just like um like you know the job of
making buildings they like building they design buildings I feel like you're lying I feel like
it's a fetish a feeder wait is it actually a feeder fetish is that what architect architect means
like big it means you like I'm thick oh you like I'm thick oh I got some of my finger
wait I have napkins what am I doing that wasn't a fart that was me ripping the napkin
it's a reference to a movie you don't want to go down the rabbit hole in me why not I like
them thick too I like thick girls it was not a fart it was not I would be very honest with you if
it was a fart I literally farted in my microphone yesterday why is my holy shit wait I'm trying
to see how far behind my stream is it's not that far behind I missed the fart yesterday it's still
up you can go look at it it's still up don't you worry pookie it don't you worry your little head
I think I added too much water it's like disgustingly slimy god it looks like I'm just playing with
caca I don't have okay I don't have a poop kink I just like pee pee poo poo jokes I just like
poo poo jokes okay I don't actually have a poop kink
motto motto I I am motto motto I like them big I like them chunky I like them big something
look out I think motto motto likes you alright I'm gonna go microwave this disgusting piece of shit
I shouldn't have tasted it it tastes really disgusting oh my god that some people sent me a
marshmallow saying they wanted to hear me gagging on their dick so there you go that's exactly what
it would sound like okay I'm gonna go microwave this I'm gonna put it in for 30 seconds and then
I'm also gonna clean up my freaking straw because these bitches be licking on it
I'm back I'm back
okay so this is what it looks like after being um as someone's going to be the new member feeler
at this point she's gonna be the sixth member no don't don't don't lose my rat absolutely not
I missed you oh I missed you too hey I swear I had oh wait I think I put it in here
maybe not whatever so this is our uh burger it seems like
wait so this is half of our burger
I didn't think she would be able to actually take it out of the freaking
it's okay we can make do we can make do we can make it work um this is kind of gross
right there's our burger
there's our burger stop I'm gonna put this burger into the container of food
yeah country girls make do okay so this burger is gonna go with the rest of the food that I've
made that I've created
oh what's next
next is the cheese okay
wait did you steal my cheese did you I'm supposed to have cheese
ah shit yeah this is your bento blocks for tomorrow at school yep I'm making your I'm
making your lunch for tomorrow um is this the cheese this is the cheese right this looks like cheese
okay
say this is the cheese
I think it's the cheese where does the cheese go I'm supposed to mix it in here okay
okay
what breed is that turtle it's a golden retriever let me clean this out say jeezu
blue cheese I think it's just in a blue container for some reason I don't know why
and there goes my spoon there goes my spoon okay great there goes my spoon
and now they're fighting probably for the spoon um
I'm losing my god damn sanity okay I guess I'll just use the freaking scissors to mix it
we should do a part two to this where I make the other one all right
I guess I just put it in here and then I only put
one container of the water apparently excuse me
that's full of trash get your head out of the trash now you have
particles all over your face what happened what happened why is your face covered what happened
by the way I don't I don't abuse my rats I know she's flinching a lot she just hates being touched
and um she hates being touched and pet and picked up um she's not flinching because I hit her
he hits you does okay she just stole my freaking she just he hits you doesn't he I don't hit my poor
rats she just hates being touched that's all right
guys they're fighting over the shit that they stole from me right now I can hear them squeaking
right this is truly a crack house we make do with what we can
yeah she just thinks it's a game this is a game of how much can she steal from Amy
the more items you get the more points you get we collect more points
it's this is not a crack house it's a crack home
let me put a little more water more okay there
all right look this cheese actually looks pretty good aren't you excited to eat the
to eat the the lunch I made for you for tomorrow it's gonna be so yummy you're gonna love it
I definitely didn't trim my pubes with these scissors
actually I feel like you would like that wouldn't you you creep your freaky little creep
I mean pubes what pubes I don't have pubes
okay now I have to shave this on on the cutting they gave us a little cutting board
this is a cutting board now I have to shape it into a squishy
okay there
um oh god wait it kind of smells cheesy
uh kind of very very minimally very minimally cheesy
pubes I call that garnish
oh my god you're disgusting garnish
deliciously cheesy or no how does it go dangerously cheesy is that the Doritos
I'm trying to like line it up somehow there I do have real cheese I can put in your burger if
you want real cheese it's right next to me I might have to just put real cheese
because I'm having a lot of trouble making it square shaped
okay should I flatten it maybe no it's just not gonna stick to itself I thought this was candy it
is candy it's candy that I'm putting in your lunch tomorrow all right there's your cheese
you're welcome I tried really hard for this okay so you better eat it all
would you do a toe stamp what's a toe stamp what's a toe stamp
Amy it looks amazing oh thank you so much candy's nuts I think guess the button is
finally full she finally left me alone um
um what is this is this a ketchup
all right
finally the last thing we're making is ketchup
do you like ketchup I like ketchup and I like mustard and I also like mayonnaise mayonnaise is
my favorite um condiment yep I know controversial I know controversial but mayonnaise is my favorite
condiment I dip me I dip my fries in mayonnaise I dip my burgers in mayonnaise I dip my chicken nuggets
and I dip my chip chip chip chicken nuggets I dip my chicken nuggets in mayonnaise I dip what else
do I dip in mayonnaise what else can you dip in mayonnaise
wait how am I supposed to put this on the
how am I supposed to put this on the burger
I dip my finger in mayonnaise is mayonnaise an instrument
yeah right the thoughts on mayo and pizza
you're going a little too far now oh wait how am I supposed to mix this
I'm just gonna use this to mix it oh wait didn't I use this to mix it last time I can use this
I'll just use this
hollandaise I've never tried hollandaise sauce from from my memory I don't think
I think I don't know I'm not sure if I tried hollandaise sauce before
ranch on pizza is delicious that sounds great I like ranch
hollandaise is god tier
I think I've tried hollandaise on like
breakfast oh this is really
oh my god it smells so bad
I've never wanted to lick a pair of scissors more than now
I'm okay I'm okay it's just really gross okay well I can't actually um
I can't make the coke it's supposed to come with coke but Esteban stole my coke cup so
yeah oh here's the cola but Esteban stole my cup for my cola so um that's not happening
all right let's put this stuff away
and um let's put this stuff away because that's for the cola
this is for the fries this is for the cola that we don't have
just eat the powder I don't I can't even handle smelling um I can't even handle smelling the
freaking ketchup get your nose out of the ketchup so I'm not gonna be eating the powder okay
wait oh wait
stop it
right some people have had some questions about whether or not I will post on my um previous
channel I got some mayonnaise some mayonnaise I got some marshmallows about that no I'm not
gonna be posting on my previous channel when I'm um during oh wait I'm not gonna be posting on my
previous channel while I'm um Amy um and also I will not be updating the my previous patreon while
I'm Amy because I just don't have don't have the time strongy on the other hand holy shit I don't
know how she does everything she does but I just can't so yeah I'm sorry apologies for that
should I I need tape oh I don't want to get the tape um
and also um I will not be opening reopening the the previous patreon subscriptions because
then that's gonna charge people and I don't I'm not gonna be making new content so why would I
charge people however comma not that I encourage it but if you really really want to listen to the
old content it's out there for you unfortunately unfortunately it's out there if you really want
to find it okay I need tape um okay let me go get tape and then I'm gonna put it all together
our wick here's all here's our wick donald's tray
what is strani's other channel I don't know other channel what did I say that no I didn't say that
I don't know I don't know what you're talking about
hey brb
so
okay
um yeah strani other channel what you want to but I don't know I don't know
hello hello hello welcome is our new people suddenly joining what do you mean every artist
hates their work what no that's not what I mean I don't mean unfortunately as in I hate the previous
content I'm just saying the previous patreon content is is out there if you want to find it
unfortunately that's what I mean and also I don't know if I if I should like post it like on
this account because I know people want to listen to it it's kind of locked behind a paywall
right now a paywall that you can't even pay so you it's not even locked behind a paywall it's just
locked but um it would feel weird because it's not even my name like um it's my other name so it's
like you're not I don't know I feel like I don't know people are really scared that I'm gonna leave
don't worry I love you don't leave um um is this is this it do I just close this
can I you still keep in contact with pointless any others um
who I don't know who you're talking about
I'm kidding I have internet friends of course I keep in contact with my internet friends
that'd be mean to just leave them I have a lot of internet friends that I kept in contact with
from before that'd be so mean to just leave you think you think I just leave all of my friends
no no I love the friends that I met through ASMR because sorry um I kind of had to but the people
that I've met through other ways like through streaming um or through like fellow ASMR artists
of course I would keep in contact with fellow oh wait that's not the trash can of course I would
keep in contact with those people they're my friends and you're my friends too don't worry you're my
friends too strawney's home for sad girls what are you trying to say what are you trying to say
huh
I'm searching amybzu on patreon it doesn't pop up yeah because my account does um nsfw content
you have to just find it through the link I'm pretty sure you have to click on the link
lunch is ready for school should I eat it
it tastes like nothing
okay I'm gonna try to there we go so this is the bottom patty and this is the top patty
and then there's your um there's your burger patty oh sorry this is the top bun this is the
top bun and this is the no this is the bottom bun and this is the top bun and then this is
your patty and then that's your cheese oh shit um your cheese fell a little bit and then here's your
fries are we on a diet no what do you mean this is so much food this is literally so much food
like just looking at this I'm I'm getting full just even thinking about all this food
so there's your fries
there you go fuck go in okay there's your fries there's this is your top bun oh wait right of
course your um your ketchup your ketchup there you go my god ew your ketchup
ew so yummy in my tummy
I think I wanted to divorce divorce was never an option absolutely not
all right oh ew okay
there you go there's there's your um your lunch for tomorrow
oh
doesn't it look appetizing doesn't it look so yummy
don't you just want to eat it all up right now
I know I did so good it's so yummy
here let me give you a little taste because you look so excited open wide
should I try it no I'm too scared I'm too scared
I'm such a good sister look at me
now the question is um
oh my god please don't look at my notifications
that's nothing important anyways
actually whatever
I know I'm so talented
a blue logo what do you mean a blue logo
there's no blue logo
right um
um
the question is should I make another one or should I um
should I should I end here what do you want
should I make this one this one kind of feels easier to make or maybe actually it looks harder
that's up to you baby girl
it means so good at cooking she could be your wife but can you sanity handle another one
if Esteban isn't here to fuck me over all the time maybe
you never end the broadcast you're still hungry okay I'll make another one for you
just for you because you asked so nicely I'll make another one how are you feeling I'm feeling
okay I could go on a little bit longer I'll make another one well Esteban get involved
probably I can see her peeking from the corner at me um
I I don't normally like to waste food but I'm not gonna eat this so it's going in a trash
I'm sorry I'm sorry cancel me cancel me I'm sorry
I want to bring a garbage can too
so hopefully this one will be less less scuffed because Esteban seems to have had her fill
think of the homeless rats what am I doing there's homeless rats out there that could be
that could that could be eating that food what am I even thinking throwing out throwing it out
I'm so not thankful what's it called I'm so I don't know all right so this one's sushi
okay let's take a little snack break and eat some cheese I'll chat with you a little while I eat my cheese
I'm grateful yeah spoiled brat you guys were kind of quick with that come on now
I'll just snack on some cheese while I read while I read chat well we can talk
every time I like move a little bit I'm scared that I'm gonna show you my freaking feet
do you have a favorite type of cheese I like Havarti but I like it um
there's a specific brand that puts like herbs in it and that's my favorite
what's your favorite type of cheese let me know and don't say you don't like cheese
no one no one hates cheese even lactose intolerant people will will eat cheese because it's that good
cheezus give us cheese pepper jack mm I never tried pepper jack lots of people gouda okay come on
that's my finger okay shredded shredded is not as type of cheese shredded is not a type of cheese
cream cheese okay non dairy cheese okay we found the oh my knife is here there it is
I thought I lost you forever
best cheese is imito cheese you want some you want some you want some
god my toes are so disgusting too I haven't freaking I haven't cut them in a long time
not my toes but my toenails
can you say cheese to meet you mmm cheese to meet you
I mean if you're offering does it grip does it grip though
ayo what's the gripping power on those grippers
why are people saying mating press what do you mean by that what do you mean mating press what
do you mean where are you on what cut your toes in me
where are you pressing dude it's a vt meme oh oh I don't know that meme
wait what I don't know that meme I don't know what you guys are talking about
okay I'm done eating my cheese oh this one looks really fun
cheese to meet you mating press what does that mean what does that mean what do you
can can someone explain the mean to the meme to me
you shouldn't know that meme why look how cute look they even have the little oh why is the exposure so
bad this is how dark it actually is they even have a little talk what's it called oh no the
little the little guy the little the little the little hot dog guy
mating press is a certain position okay I know that who pressing they meet
it's a baby meme I'm at an it's an image of Ollie saying cheese to meet you and then she gets
meeting press oh oh okay okay and they're seeing that meme before interesting okay
wait should I cut this out too oh it's like we're on a little picnic together look at that
is picnic time
stop sexualizing my rats guys come on I know you're degenerates but don't say anything gross
about the rats you'll be all are being disgusting the only rat you're allowed to sexualize is me
when I'm in the rat costume okay okay
are you talking about ollie oh wait bae bae bae not ollie
do your rats fart a lot they don't fart at all do you fart a lot I bet you do
yeah I bet you're yeah I bet you're a little stinker aren't you I bet you'd be stinking up the whole place
I'm guessing I need this for your size reference not as much as me
me I wish I had my freaking model to show you how sad I am when you said that
smash next question
someone got me the rat suit actually thank you for that I'm gonna totally wear that one day
I don't know how I'm gonna show you but fucking I'm gonna I mean if you're gonna get me a rat suit
I'm gonna be wearing that rat suit uh oh stinky
I mean thank you for letting me know
just crop out the face what face my face is not in the picture you are not seeing my face are you
no
rat suit 5k special no okay she's trying to get herself cut now
no 5k is too easy 5k is way too easy we can't do 5k it's gotta be like oh sorry it's gotta be
like something harder than 5k 10k okay maybe 10k there if we get to 10k I'll I'll do something
with that rat costume oh fuck you in that rat costume no
sorry sorry I'm a little stingy I know I know the other girls have been so kind to you and they've
been letting you they've been they've been letting letting you hear them pee and then and they've been
you know what else have they done that I haven't done yet I don't know I think that's about it
they just let you hear them pee I'm the only one you haven't heard pee actually Starnie hasn't peed
either has she I'm not sure if she has
they're letting you guys hear them pee yeah on twitter
dude get with the program come on on twitter I've been hearing them pee which is crazy
I mean I'm I mean what I haven't been listening to them pee what no I haven't been listening
to my gem mates pee have you tried I see ice cream no I have not maybe one day I will
I feel like this hand cam is very cluttered isn't it
can you see good fucking hell open I regret hearing I see as I thought it was a joke no
no no it's not a joke it's not a joke they're actually doing it which is so funny to me
honestly honestly honestly honestly I wasn't even gonna post any audios of myself on my NSFW
until shebe did it and I was like oh that's what that's for because they gave me my NSFW
twitter and they're like okay sorry you're not allowed to post you're not allowed to post art of
like NSFW art of yourself and I was like are you fucking kidding me what the fuck am I supposed
to do with an NSFW twitter now then just horny post that's it and then shebe posted I mean I'm
still posting art of myself I don't care I don't care if my account gets banned it gets banned
but anyways um shebe posted herself um posted an audio of herself on her twitter and I was like
oh that's what we're supposed to do okay great got it I'm doing that
do you plan on doing lives on twitter not at the moment no not at the moment
your toes are not in frame good
life is so unfair I know I know you have to wait to hear me pee I know I'm so unfair to you
why can't you post an NSFW of yourself um
it's a complicated situation just know me and Icy were told that we shouldn't um and yeah
but I'm still doing it because I don't care I don't care I want candy um okay
oh my god okay first is the green thing what is this celery broccoli broccoli
I actually hate broccoli broccoli tastes really gross to me do you like what broccoli
like broccoli smells really good I wonder if this smells like broccoli
no it smells like candy oh you know what this one actually smells really good compared to the other
one um I'm so I'm supposed to use a thing for water finally Esteban left me alone so I can
actually cook in peace broccoli is great you guys be liking broccoli that's kind of gross man
not Thanksgiving candy broccoli Rob rock is okay broccoli just tastes like grass though
doesn't it
once a month I guess ain't the biggest fan either your veggies make me you can't make me
me micro plastics wow I just love eating micro plastics
the taste of the plastic entering my body and never leaving is just so amazing
is this enough how much do I need
one
broccoli I do eat some vegetables but you're gonna be disappointed by the amount I eat
I like spinach I like lettuce I like tomatoes
um
are you gay why are you acting so gay big brothers exist to eat your broccoli for you
that's why you love us also yes I do enjoy it hey thank you for the 420 I think that was 420
I'm I'm like on the floor so I have a hard time seeing yeah exactly that's why you exist to eat
my broccoli for me I don't need to yeah 420 thank you I don't need to eat the
I don't eat I don't need to eat the broccoli you're here to eat the broccoli cabbage I don't
like cabbage carrots I don't like carrots um um I think that's pretty much it I think that's
all the vegetables I like is there anything I left out I can kind of handle carrots if they're
baby carrots um beautiful hands bro my hands are fat as fuck
don't even talk to me about my hands I hate I hate how jubby they are
squash slash zucchini I hate those two
oh there it comes your hands are cute I got skinny hands I wish I had skinny hands
bro I've never in my entire life had skinny hands they've always been weirdly chubby I don't
know why and then when I exercise they get like um swollen should I try this I want to give it a try
and it's okay it's a lot better than the other one
her mountain her little sister I'd still put a ring on them oh thank you
you
what do you mean little sister's hands kind of lose
do you think it's sexy watching me cook um
oh trash fellow
um toe peeking
damn it how am I supposed to sit comfortably when I can't show toe
I guess Shibi also showed her toes too yeah
it's this one right I haven't done that yet
is my toe still peeking god damn it please hide yourself a little bit of modesty here
you're acting like a cheap whore in me um this one I think it's this one
I'm gonna guess it's this one
is it not this one
what is this what is this what even is this yellow stuff
oh it's oh oh it's this one it's this one okay I almost put in the wrong one
I know put some slippers on I know I'm sorry I'm sorry they're gonna fire me for being so
loot on stream I gotta be careful
wait what are you rating did I farted I mean did I farted did I burp
what kind of pose are you streaming on to get so many accidents until toe slips I'm just sitting
crisscross applesauce on my floor that's all you can see like my leg here crisscross applesauce
did I forwarded yeah did I burp
no slippers we need to toe oh I burped I didn't even remember that how much in here just one okay
you already forgot you'd be surprised how much I forgot I don't even know my mom's birthday
I don't know any of my family member's birthdays
it's really depressing I really forget a lot dude I forgot my age once
I forgot my age and because I'm so bad at math I was struggling to calculate it
and I was asking my mom like wait mom how old am I if I was born in in this year how old am I
okay I think that's good
and now the sausage that's normal though is it is it
did you ever smoked weed no I never smoked it um
where's the sausage I've tried edibles before but they didn't these edibles didn't do shit
these edibles didn't do shit so I've never actually I don't think I've ever really experienced
the feeling of the weed did you do you drink vodka you guys are you guys ask some funny questions
I don't drink vodka no I only like um I see was actually drinking it today well during her DJ
stream she said she was drinking Baileys I love Baileys that's the only alcohol I will drink
okay well it's not the only alcohol I'll drink but it's the only alcohol I like to drink
and so I usually only get like Irish cream
these edibles ain't shit
it keeps you anxiety then don't take it don't drink it
I see drank a bit too much and got very personal with the snowberries did she oh no is it like a
bad thing did something bad happen is she okay what did she say a lot of girls like Baileys I just
I guess I'm just like every other girl then
no it was all good oh that's good I'm just gonna slap my cheese here for now
you don't mind me slapping my cheese down right here do you
it was great she was just very open about her desires oh oh oh shit I see
I see be careful on YouTube geez oh my you don't mind if I just slap my cheese over here do you
and rid them to some of the songs that's kind of cute hello
she was getting spicy oh
she wanted certain fluids in certain places what the I see oh my god
you know what fuck it that's where my toe is going to be from now on yep that's where it's
staying I don't care anymore
sorry I just I fucking love cheese
the vlog got spicy wait did she oh fuck what am I doing my thing a little bit still be here come on
okay are you a rat I'm not surprisingly there's a human attached to those toes
it may have been a good thing oh it may have been a good thing it was
unarchived oh she had to unarchive it silly girl I would never do something so bad that my
stream would have to be an archive me never
hello if the bomb
um
why are you guys putting x oh x to doubt
so is he spiked her vodka no she just drank too much that's all that's all
right right sorry I'm being distracted okay let's make this sausage
not sure what you could spike vodka to make it even stronger I don't know um shrooms
um I'm trying to think of like some crazy hard drugs fentanyl is that how you pronounce it
ever clear gasoline don't steal that
ketamine methamphetamine what's ever clear what's that you want to lick it clean
oh such a good girl oh thank you you're so cute oh my god I love you please never die
okay anyways um
um what's next careful the rice is next
what's the rice is this the rice this is the rice
every killer is like 80 to 90 percent
Pepsi goes well with vodka I wouldn't know because vodka tastes like
shit so I would never I would never I would never drink vodka on purpose um where does this go
um this one goes in here okay
I like paint fluid did you guys hear uh I'm thinking of a story but I forgot it
there was there's like Reddit stories or here I'll tell you multiple stories because I just
thought of another one did you guys see the freaking post about that guy on the internet
that like he made a post on the internet right and he was like he posted a picture of his um
he posted a picture of his leg I think and it was covered in bruises and he was like I don't know
he's the the caption was like days blah blah blah blah day something um of trying to micro dose
bullets until I'm bullet proof it days something I've tried to micro dose
bullets until I'm bullet proof fucking hell open oh my god okay and his leg was covered
in like scars and then eventually he like posted another update and he was like guys
I went up I don't remember the guns that he was using or like the bullets that he was using
he literally said it was working too he was like my um my bullets have no longer been like
breaking skin okay get your nose out of there okay I need two of these he said my bullets
have no longer been breaking skin so I'm gonna move up to the next like gun I don't know next
gun or next bullets he might be onto something right and so um that's what he did and then he ended
up in the he ended up in the hospital after that yeah next caliber I don't know bro was bullet
maxing he ended up in the hospital after that and he was like guys I'm gonna stop micro dosing
bullets and then he started
okay um
sorry I'm just rewatching the stream to see the clip of of S1 trying to um take my my packaging
why am I so far behind on stream okay well whatever guys tell me if you see my face okay
that's embarrassing but anyways um what was I talking about
we didn't even see your hair I was hoping for a hair reveal I'm spilling water everywhere
um why does my stream so delayed on my end what the hell
okay there we go right micro dosing bullets um
um um so he went up to the next caliber and then he was like guys he ended up in the hospital
he was like guys I can't do this anymore I'm gonna stop but if anyone wants to pick up
like pick up my my challenge like basically just saying like guys you should try this too
um I just thought that was hilarious and then he started being like an asshole about the nurse
and saying like yeah I'm gonna fuck the nurse in the hospital which yeah sure yeah of course the guy
who would try to micro dose bullets would be creepy like that no face just be perfect how I like it
S1 has been waiting on the phone so that may be the uh walking on the phone yeah that's true
okay but was the nurse hot though I don't know why are you asking it doesn't even matter
it doesn't matter if she was hot do you like her huh are you looking for a girlfriend in the nurse
you know being a streamer probably pays just as much as being a nurse these days
so maybe you should just stick with me okay
why isn't my race racing the way I want it to race only in me only in me perfect perfect
ill women are you gay why are you acting so gay right now
I need more water
I caught my socks on oh so it's not gay
there you go it means the best sister in the world and she's the only girl I
need in my life and I love her a lot good job good job you're doing good I've trained you well
right what was I saying so the other story I had was of I think it's a Reddit story I'm not sure
it was of this girl who was man I wish I could remember I really wish I had better memories
so I could tell you tell you about it better but it was from this girl and I think she had this
weird obsession with like people you know giving her attention for being sick so she would pretend
to be sick online um and I think it got to the point where she was like
every female I come across wait what I see every female I come across as a potential partner
what is wrong with you why would you say that to me
I'm the only potential partner shut up do you want this up your ass because you're acting
like it right now or even better this one okay anyways so this girl would pretend to be sick
online and I think she would um
um Fixie's here come here don't be scared come on come closer come closer
she's so scared it's okay come closer come to the light do you see her
is it all oh I'm sorry you're scared she's oh
hi baby
every time I move she gets scared
okay bye bye
okay great
did you recently adopt her is that why she's scared um
female rats tend to be more skittish I notice that male rats just in general
um
she is also recently adopted yeah so she hasn't been outside of her cage much this is like
probably the second time I've let her free roam around my entire room so yeah she's a little spooked
um what was I talking about right right so I think what she would do is I feel like I need to get
closer let's get let's get up close and personal here um what she would do is that she would um
pick at her leg I guess which same same but she would pick at her leg and like
at one point it got um
yo don't like the don't don't like the scissors at one point it got infected
and she kept picking at it because you know she was like posting photos online I guess
and um
it got to the point where she had like an entire hole
in her leg like through her leg like you could see through her leg because if she got
like it got so bad because it got infected I think by the way don't take these stories as like
100% like this is what happened like these are stories I've seen on the internet but I might be
fucking them up because I don't remember them correctly okay so just know that
um yeah she got a hole through stop touching me it might be a little spooky um she got a hole
through her leg and I saw the picture and it was so scary yeah I'm on Chow's and that's what it's called
I can't believe that Amy's friend did that what my friend no I don't know this person it was an
internet story what do you mean Amy wait wait wait wait and I spilled more water
okay no it's just an internet story
rock maxing literally rock maxing you're scaring us no no I don't pick at my leg like that
not to that degree absolutely not not even close not even close she it was just scary it was scary
at a co-worker who's leg got infected and they kept scratching at it they were told to stop and
they ended up losing their leg holy fucking shit dude that's literally something I would do
oopsies
that's literally something I would do I would do that shit I would do that bullshit that's literally
me oh my god that's scary you're scared now you're scaring me
Amy you don't happen to have any holes in your legs do you no I don't I don't
don't lose your legs I promise I promise I will I will I will
I think I'll stop biting my lip I still be biting my lips too
if you cannot this would you let would uh if you cannot this I would let you pick me good
I would I would pick you
okay that's my triangle race shape
my stepdad knew a guy who kept amputating parts of his toes he just chopped off every once in a
while wait he just chopped off a bit every once in a while oh my god he's trying to make himself
grow his limbs back isn't he that's what he was trying to do he was trying to get his limbs to grow
back so if he chopped off a little at a time it would slowly grow back dude what a freaking
Elon Musk who uh what other smart people uh Elon Musk isn't smart um what other smart people
will Albert Einstein who I only know that guy is this what I'm supposed to use it is
yeah regeneration maxing micro dosing dismemberment
so funny micro dosing dismemberment okay I think this
so I fill up all of these okay I'm gonna fill up I'm gonna fill them up
what does this say it says nutty I was just saying what it is
okay I'm just gonna pull a little bit then
and he hates Elon he ruined twitter
he freaking shadowbanned me from twitter of course I hate him it's okay though my twitter is okay now
okay that's a little bit terrifying
there was that one guy earlier this year who got convinced to freeze his legs with dry ice until
he lost them for insurance money and then got caught dude there's like people who I'm just gonna
put the rest in here I think that's right there's like people who identify as now we're just talking
about mental illness at this point what a great topic for me I'm kidding I'm not gonna talk about
my own but um there's like people who I saw I saw it on like those tlc shows there's people who
identify as like handicapped and then they will literally handicap themselves to to to be the handicap
that they like identified with like the lady that like put bleach in her eyes so that she um
so that she was blind because she wanted to be blind isn't that crazy I don't know I think I
need to start dipping because this is no longer getting deep enough in
nut bars they are nut bars
how many how many do I put how much oh please don't stick please don't stick
okay she stole my race for a little bit but I got it back um do I just put a little bit I don't
get it did I do it did I do it
and then do I put the rest in here
oh shit I wasn't supposed to put oops I wasn't supposed to put any water in
I identify as Imi's brother you are my brother you don't need to identify as that
the fury that amputated his his hands so he could have paws what
that guy in japan who had surgery done on him to become a dog
while they're fighting I think you're thinking I think I'm thinking of but I think we're thinking
of the same guy was I even supposed to add water to this I don't think I was supposed to add water
to this I think I was literally just supposed to stamp it oh I'm a fucking dumbass now there's
hair on my race average makima fan
there's your nori that looks gross I was just supposed to stamp it wasn't I
and then I was supposed to roll these in the black
powder so that they would be the ears for the
ew this looks so gross
keep the hair in guys don't be disgusting ew ew oh it's so wet and then I have to add the face
how am I gonna add the oh god oh this is gonna be cursed there's his face
um oopsies
it's so funny to see what the mods delete I will write by the way if there's any mods watching I
will write um I will write a guidelines for you for the chat I will do that I will do that very
soon so that way you know what to what to do I'm sorry I've been like I've been I've been um neglecting
you um okay and now the last one is this one
thanks for the hard words yes thank you is this does this have a hole in it
I'm not gonna have a taste no and then this other person that also identified as a handicap
like wanted to be in a wheelchair or something this is gross oh wait I have a
I have a garbage can what am I doing they wanted to be in a wheelchair or something so they um
they laid down on train tracks and had the train like cut their legs off
okay now she's going in my trash and then the train did it because of course it would
um how many do I put in here one yeah no I'm putting more than one
do not resuscitate at that point I mean like why would the train do that
why would the train do that is the train stupid
is the train stupid why would it do that
I mean can you be Japanese a little bit I took eight months of Japanese class but that doesn't
mean I can read it well and also I haven't like practiced in a long time
that's why I didn't name it as a as a language that I know because I don't really know it
I can try reading what it says this says dekiyakari right dekiyakari oh you can't even see it
I don't know what dekiyakari means though
this says tsukuro tsukuro or bento there you go my very limited Japanese knowledge
oh ready to eat oh that's what it means enjoy your food ready to eat whoa first step stop watching
dumb shut up I will do as I please with my anime and no one's allowed to tell me what otherwise
I mean studying Japanese here gana and katakana is easy kanji is hard as fuck
I find kanji to be easier because oftentimes like there you can find pictures in the kanji
that help you remember what it means um yeah but that's just me that's just me being a little
special
I'm pretty sure kanji is based off of pictures anyways so it's not even just me it's just facts
there are a lot of kanji you're right you're right there are I think I think we're we're almost there
um
so now I just put it in this bag
kanji is easier if you learn slash you know Chinese that's true that's true that's very true
because I think they have the same meanings
oh this is the noodle oh okay okay
okay
all right are you ready to plate the food because it's about to be plated get ready to eat go wash
your hands
I'm about to noodle you up that's right I think I gotta push it in more
or here let me cut it let me cut the bottom you know it's so gross and slimy you
you
all right
so where does the noodles go I want to I want to copy it I want to copy the the packaging
wait what are these meatballs wait when did we make meatballs oh I was supposed to make
meatballs before the noodles okay we'll make me we'll make the meatballs last all right
so here is I'll put the noodles first so here's your noodles
come on
um
um go out come on oh so it won't come out
so yummy yummy in my tummy
it looks like a pile of shit
it looks like a pile of shit gross yummy in my tummy
don't you just want to lick that up
okay and then we have our our our rice our rice panda oh then we have our rice panda
cute let me bring this closer
there
and then we have all right our broccoli how do I get the broccoli
it broke a little bit sorry about that there's your broccoli this looks so disgusting
and then we have what do we have next all this thing
um
yeah how do I it's so slimy okay I'm supposed to roll this thing up but it won't I think I put
too much water it's falling apart oh guys I just picked my nose can you clean my finger for me
okay
what is this supposed to be is this supposed to be like yum or something
okay okay there's the I don't know I don't even know what that's supposed to be
and then there's the other rice I think the hot dog is oh it's supposed to be rolled egg really
I think the hot dog's gonna be the only one that actually looks good no it doesn't look good
this is what a fetus looks like at six weeks you murder
okay sorry let's not get political um okay great now that's all that's left is the meatballs
um
okay
um this is water in for our Swedish meatballs along with I don't know why we're making meatballs
for a Japanese bento but we're doing it so
I'm trying to think of some crazy some other crazy shit internet shit I've seen
there's a lot apparently one guy tried to recreate uh I forget which youtuber it was
some vtuber's pee that's why I said that's why I posted my um my what does your oh she
smell like post and I said okay use this to recreate my pee he like tracked like what kind
of food she ate too which you know and then he would drink it while watching her like while watching
her what's her name Sui Suisei Suisei Suisei yeah the Sui piss yeah that that's okay I think
that's so funny like like I know some people genuinely are really creeped out by that I think
it's the most funniest shit ever I think it's hilarious all right there's our meatballs I don't
have a toothpick to put in the meatballs like they have here a toothpick but it's you know it's
I don't even need a toothpick to be honest because it already looks just like the packaging basically
like
oops
corporate wants you to find the difference between these two pictures
they're the same picture it looks exactly like the packaging um
yeah what a romantic little picnic date we have here
it looks perfect thank you
don't you just want to I don't want to eat it I'm scared I'm not going to eat it I'm not going
to eat it I don't want to eat it I'm scared
who needs real food when you have me to cook you this
eat the sausage oh I kind of have to don't I I kind of joked about eating it
can we take a little bite out of it this was slimy
I bit his head off
okay I tried not to gag I didn't gag but um
just the tip just the tip I just got the tip but um yeah
thank you for thank you for cooking with me chat and also thank you for cooking with my rats
and dealing with their shenanigans
so proud of you I'm proud of myself too for making it this far in my cooking journey
it's really um
it's really yummy
okay
it's just looking at it makes me gag like I'm not even joking and also it didn't taste good
um can you show us your rats again
you can you can look at the vod I'm too lazy to get up I'm so tired you could look at the vod
um thank you for coming I love you I'll see you tomorrow what are we doing tomorrow oh yeah
we're trying to get characters without my glasses oh fuck I have to prepare for that okay well
thank you for coming yeah I made it with love
I passed out six times but your um your bento is ready
okay I'll see you um don't stay here because I'm gonna redirect you into someone else but
yeah I'll see you I will see you tomorrow
you